[Music]
hey you guys
time once again for tomes of terror
where i discuss
the latest horror book that i've read
over the past week the one we're talking
about today
is one that had kind of a um a lot of
buzz when it first came out i believe it
first was published back in 2017
this little sort of a haunted house
novel
called kill creek by scott
thomas now interestingly uh i believe
this is scott thomas's first
novel he actually got his start doing a
lot of
writing for tv and weirdly a lot of it
was like children's tv
like he did some stuff for the cartoon
network and he did a lot of stuff for
the disney channel
he even did some stuff um i think he did
sort of like a horror theme show that
was kind of you know
why a that was based on like r.l stein
stories i haven't seen it
but um i think he got like an emmy
nomination for that so he kind of got
started out like writing for
kids tv he did some [ __ ] for like vh1
and mtv and stuff like that too
um but i guess so this is his first
horror novel and it was published in
2017 through ink shares
and i have to say like for a first
horror novel this was um
pretty amazing i had a really really
good time with this book
it was never boring it never lagged it
is a haunted house story and
you know of a sort and it's not super
original it has like a lot of shades of
uh you know the shining and
things of that nature in it but that
said i mean
this was a really interesting story that
went in a lot of directions that i
didn't
expect so for that reason alone and also
the character work even though the
characters i have to say like in maybe
in the first
portion of the book kind of started out
as very sort of
stereotypical or you know archetype type
characters
but i think that as the story went on
they kind of became more complex
and you know they they each had their
own like unique character arc which i
thought was very well done
so as i usually say for these
discussions
i'm not necessarily going to spoil the
ending or spoil
any big huge plot twists or anything
like that however
it is very difficult to talk about a
book like this without spoiling at least
some things about it so
if you want to come at this book without
knowing anything about where it's going
then i would recommend you read it first
and then come back and discuss it
because like i said i like to approach
books without you know knowing as little
as possible about them you know i i know
a lot of other people like to do that
too because i like to be surprised and
you know i like to see where the author
is going to take me like on the journey
or whatever
so here's the setup of this book
now our main character it's kind of an
ensemble
piece there's like a lot of characters
in it uh many of which are horror
writers
but sort of the main character the every
man type character that we're seeing
most things uh you know unfold through
is named sam mcgarver now he's kind of
like
your sort of standard mainstream horror
writer in the sense that he's been very
successful he writes horror novels that
are
scary enough to appeal to horror fans
but also not so scary as like
to turn off mainstream audiences so he's
kind of i guess you could say he's kind
of like a stephen king
type of guy like but he's like a bit
younger
now at the beginning of the story though
even though he's been quite successful
so far
he's kind of um hit a bit of a slump uh
him and his wife have just broken up
like his wife has
left him they're separated and um
he has not been able to get into his
next book like his agent is sitting
there saying you know we need a new book
from you this year like by the end of
this year and he's like yeah yeah i'm
working on it but he's really not um he
really doesn't have
two ideas to rub together and uh he just
keeps lying and saying that he's working
on something but he's really not so he's
having kind of a hard time
also he has something of a sort of dark
traumatic past which
is kind of given away in little hints
here and there you know that something
bad happened to him when he was a child
that had to do with
um you know a house fire and other
things
and he has like scars on his arm or
whatever but they don't tell you exactly
what happens until probably like the end
even though you could probably like
figure it out
so what ends up happening with sam is
that
he gets contacted by this dude named
wainwright
now wainwright is sort of like this
young
hotshot type uh internet tycoon type of
guy
i guess he's kind of like in his 30s or
whatever and he's real stylish
and his dad is a billionaire i think and
so
he's pretty much um has all the money he
needs to
indulge in his various proclivities now
wayne wright is really really into
horror
and he's specifically interested one in
getting more mainstream audiences
interested in horror
and also he likes to take things that
are sort of obscure
and kind of bring them back into the
like things that are forgotten or
something like that that have to do with
horror you know like creepy old haunted
houses or whatever
so he's very much into that and because
he has a lot of money he has started
this
website on which they do sort of these
horror themed events and he tries to do
something different all the time
um so wayne wright contacts sam mcgarver
sam being a very
uh popular horror writer and he has a
proposal for him he's basically like
well um halloween is coming up and we
want to do this really big
event and we want to
interview you uh at this supposedly
haunted house that a lot of people have
kind of forgotten about which was kind
of like um you know there were urban
legends about it like back in the day
but it's
sort of gone under the radar since then
like since the 70s i believe
and he's like so i want to kind of bring
this house back to the light and i also
want
you know you to be able to get out there
and say what you
want about horror and stuff and he's
like and i'll give you a hundred
thousand dollars
so at first sam is like real reluctant
he thinks that
he doesn't really trust this guy he
thinks you know there's there there's
something underhanded he's not entirely
sure
what he's like he's kind of familiar
with the website and he's like i know
how much
he likes to do these type of stunts
these times like events because they
want all these people to watch it
so he's real kind of reluctant to get on
board with it however
on the other hand it is a hundred
thousand dollars which is nothing to
sneeze at and also
he's like well maybe staying in this
house because it's in kansas the same
state that he is in and he had
actually heard the stories about it when
he was a kid he's like you know maybe
that will kind of kick start
an idea for my next novel because you
know i don't have any ideas
for it at this point so maybe it'll be
okay
so he finally agrees to do it now
what wainwright doesn't tell him though
but what he finds out later on
is that sam is not the only horror
writer
that wayne wright has asked to
participate in this project
so sam being kind of the representation
of
the ma the mainstream successful horror
writer like i said like a stephen king
type character he's that guy the
everyman
you also have uh three other horror
writers who are summoned to this meeting
with wainwright where he kind of gets
into
you know what what he wants this event
to be
now one of the other writers is a female
horror author named tc
moore and she's sort of supposed to be
like i guess i kind of saw her as sort
of like early clive barker maybe like
christa foul
or somebody like that who writes about
really really
extreme uh horror gore
fetishism eroticism you just like a lot
of bdsm a lot of you know
demon [ __ ] that type of stuff so she
does like real extreme
sexual horror she's also a very
she's a little bit i feel like her
character was
kind of one of the most divisive uh of
the book at least according to
a lot of the um reviews that i read and
i can see why
she's a little bit over the top a little
bit like a caricature she's very much
you know she's a very thin like a very
gothy sort of character
i think in the first scene i think it's
the first scene where she's introduced
she's basically like at this
meeting in la where she lives with her
um with these producers that are making
a movie out of
her latest book and she's really pissed
off because they want to make it pg-13
even though the book is like really
really extreme and she's not having it
so basically in the middle of a crowded
restaurant like in the middle of an
afternoon like she stabs one of the
dudes in the hand and all this other so
she's
she's very like over the top angry
um you know she's just very sarcastic
she's very mean
so you can say like she's kind of
unlikable i kind of dug her but um
but i could see how some people are like
yeah it's a little much
uh she does actually soften as the book
goes on um
as her character becomes more developed
as more bad [ __ ] happens
so and she does have some [ __ ] that
happened during her past
that explains like why she's so you know
misanthropic i guess
um because she is like just really rude
and terrible like to everybody
so she's one of the writers too she's
kind of like the representation of the
of extreme horror and then you have
this guy named daniel slaughter who
is i guess he's sort of like the r.l
stein stand-in he writes
uh y.a horror like for tweens and
teenagers
but with a real over-the-top um hardcore
christian
outlook it's kind of like one of those
it kind of reminded me a little bit of
like a chick tract where it's like their
horrible [ __ ] happens in the book but
it's all in the
you know in the service of getting
people it's like oh evil is always
punished you know what i mean so he kind
of writes these sort of simplistic
you know allegorical type religious
things but in a horror context
his personality also kind of reflects
that like he's very
golly gee willikers you know he's very
hardcore he goes to church all the time
he doesn't swear he doesn't drink he
doesn't do all this kind of stuff
um he's a nice enough character but he
does seem like a little
too good to be true i guess and then the
fourth writer
is an older guy he's in his 70s and his
name is sebastian cole
and he kind of comes across as sort of
the grandfatherly like mentor type
character
because all of the other younger writers
know who he is and they really like look
up to him because his
um you know books have been very lauded
and everything he kind of gave me like a
ray brad
ray bradbury type of vibe or somebody
like that and he's just like this very
sweet very elegant
uh old man you know he's very
compassionate he's very you know he's
just a lovely lovely person
he is actually in particular even though
all the writers know who he is
like sam is really like flabbergasted to
meet him because he's like you know not
only is sebastian cole
the reason that i became a horror writer
but he also kind of saved my life
because he had like a really [ __ ] up
childhood and he's like and discovering
his books
was like his way out you know what i
mean so these four writers
all gather at this meeting with
wainwright
and wayne wright lays it out to them
he's like look i'm giving you each of
you a hundred thousand dollars
we're going to go to this haunted house
called kill creek it's in kansas um the
reason the house is called kill creek is
just because
obviously there was a creek next to it
that was called kill creek
they kind of go into maybe why it was
called that
i guess because like the dutch word for
crete kind of sounds like kill or
whatever and it just maybe got uh you
know named that
and they go a little bit into the
history of the house they don't over
explain it which is actually good they
kind of leave it a little bit nebulous
but it's like it was you know built
during
you know maybe a little bit before
during the civil war
this guy built it pretty much with his
own hands
and he was a white dude but he had a
black
girlfriend who was a freed slave and
not too long after the house was
finished there was a
group of you know people like
confederate soldiers or whoever and they
came
and lynched his girlfriend and killed
him and
from then on like there were other kind
of stories about the house
so they go a little bit too into you
know some other tragedies that happened
at the house like i said they don't
belabor it which is good um probably the
most important
characters you know of the people that
lived there before were these two
sisters
uh rachel and rebecca finch and there's
kind of a story about them you know one
of them was uh you know in a wheelchair
and then you know they there were all
these kind of weird stories about them
and um i think they died in the 70s and
they kind of left the house the way it
was and they left in their will that
the house needed to be left the way it
was like don't change anything in it
like so all the furniture furniture's
still there
so basically wainwright's proposal is
he's like look i got this
book that came out in the 70s i believe
it was by a parapsychologist
and he had stayed at this house and he
talked about meeting rachel finch when
she was still alive
and he talked about all this creepy [ __ ]
that had happened in the house
and wainwright is very excited by this
book because he's like this book is out
of print now and it's like i feel like a
lot of people have forgotten about this
house even though at one time it was
very very famous
so he's like this is exactly the type of
thing i want to do he's like i want to
bring
this previously um you know well-known
legendary haunted house back to the
public since it seems everyone has kind
of forgotten about it
and he's like and while we're doing that
we're also going to promote
you for horror authors and we're going
to do it all
it's a big stunt we're going to do it
for halloween we're going to live stream
it and we're going to like you know
record everything that happens in the
house maybe some creepy [ __ ] will happen
in there
and um you know it'll be win-win for
everybody
so as i said even though some of the
writers are reluctant
tc more probably more than anybody
because she's just real cranky all
together
but finally they all agree to do it
now the interesting thing about this
book and why i said that
this kind of goes in directions that you
might not expect or at least that i
didn't expect
because what ends up happening is that
all of them go to the house
at kill creek and they're only going to
stay there
for essentially just like a day and then
they're going to stay overnight and then
they're going to leave like the next
morning so it's not like they're going
to stay there for
you know several days or anything it's
just like overnight and so they all go
there
and uh you know they have a generator
and so you know they've had the water
turned on the house
is actually even though it's been
abandoned for quite a while um
it looks like it's pr in decent
condition like better condition than you
would expect and they
make a lot about how uh the guy that
built it
back in the 1800s it's like he pretty
much built the whole thing by himself
and it's like really really beautiful
and it's really stood the test of time
like all the carving all the details and
everything
and it's actually like a really lovely
house
so they're there and uh they go through
and they do
you know they do the event they do the
interview they talk about horror the you
know it's a live stream there's millions
of people watching
and a couple of creepy things kind of
happen like
kate who is wayne wright's um girlfriend
and is also there as she's like the
technical
person so she's like videotaping
everybody and like you know controlling
the live stream and everything
now she thinks that she sees something
there's like a it's a three-story house
and there's a staircase that goes up to
the third floor
where at the top of the staircase
there's just brick so obviously
something's been bricked over
and um they can't figure out they're
trying to figure out this whole time
like
was somebody bricked in there or you
know was it bricked up just to know
to keep people out or keep people in or
whatever so they kind of think that had
something to do with the finch sisters
but they're not entirely sure
so she thinks she sees a figure
up there but she's not entirely sure
so as i said it's very strange because
the first half of the book
is basically like you're following the
four characters like i said sam
is kind of like the main character he's
like the every man stephen king type of
guy
but then it kind of jumps back and forth
to the other characters as well so you
kind of get to know them because you
know
because they all live like in vastly
different cities like i think sebastian
lives like in ithaca new york and
you know tc moore lives out in l.a or
whatever so they kind of like follow
their
lives and their motivations a little bit
so then the first half of the book is
just kind of the build up so you know
their characters and then they actually
come to the house
a couple creepy things happen they do
the interview it's very successful
millions of people watch it
and then they sleep in the house kind of
some weird [ __ ] happens like they have
like weird dreams or whatever and
you know they kind of lose track of
reality a little bit but then
you know the next morning comes and they
leave now at this point i'm reading it
i'm like
so it seemed it was weird because it
seemed like a little anticlimactic
because i'm sitting there going this
book is only halfway
through and they went to the house and a
couple
creepy things happened but nothing all
that
exciting happened like nothing all that
spooky happened and then they're just
leaving like nothing happened
you know it's like okay well that was
over and uh so i said so where are we
gonna go
from here now interestingly what happens
after that
is that the book then goes into
all of the writers you know go back to
their respective homes or whatever
and then something very interesting
starts to happen over the following
six months all four of the writers that
were in the house
they start feeling compelled to write a
new novel and it's going to be the best
novel that they ever wrote
now they are so compelled to write this
novel
that they pretty much like forget to eat
for days at a time forget to sleep or
shower for days at a time they don't
clean up their houses
so they basically kind of just go
spiraling down the drain because all
they're doing is
writing because they're just so
compelled to get this story out
now it's very interesting because during
this time period in the book we're
following sam
and he is just writing and writing and
writing and the book is she's they're
just describing like his house is just
like a [ __ ]
disaster area because he's just like not
cleaning anything up
he smells bad because he's not showering
because all he wants to do is write all
the time
there's just stacks of pages he's
written like a thousand pages or
something like that
and it's almost like he can't stop
because whenever he stops
writing the story he starts being
haunted
by the [ __ ] that happened to him when he
was a kid so he starts seeing
this apparition that you know brings
back a terrible traumatic event from his
childhood
and the only way to make that go away
and stop
appearing in his house is if he just
keeps writing
now at first he thinks he's going crazy
but then his agent comes to the house
and has been like hey um i've been
trying to call you you're not answering
your phone you're not answering your
emails what the [ __ ] is the matter with
you you look like [ __ ]
um you know you've lost weight you
haven't shaved you haven't showered um
you know no one can get a hold of you
and he's like yeah i'm working on a new
book and it's like
super super long so the agent says to
him he's like you know
i was talking to tc moore's agent
because obviously his agent knows about
the stunt that they did with wainwright
like on halloween at kill at the kill
creek house
he's like i was talking to tc moore's
agent and um no one can get hold of her
ass either
so we think that there's something weird
going on maybe you should contact her
and see what's going on
so he actually does end up
contacting her he flies out to her house
actually
like climbs over a fence and whatnot and
it turns out that tc moore has been
experiencing the exact
same thing she has been compelled to
write a novel
she has been neglecting personal hygiene
she hasn't been answering her phone
she just needs to write and write write
all the time and she is also seeing an
apparition in her house that only goes
away when she writes but is a different
apparition than what sam is seeing
because it's more personalized to her
like a trauma that she had in her past
so sam is kind of relieved because he's
like well this means i'm not crazy
because the same exact thing is
happening to her
but then in a way he's like well well
this isn't good either because this
means that
whatever it was that was in the house at
kill creek
followed us home and is somehow
manifesting as basically our worst
nightmare or worse trauma
you know writ large or whatever so
they kind of talk and they determine
that the novel that they've been writing
that they've been so compelled to write
that is like thousands and thousands of
pages
um is essentially they've written
essentially the same novel um they're
not exactly the same like the character
names are different um some
like the setting is different but the
plot of it is pretty much exactly the
same
and it's based on the kill creek house
um so once they determine that they're
like okay well we have to figure out
what the [ __ ] is going on with the other
two writers see if the same thing is
going on with them
and maybe we can meet with them and we
can figure out what the hell is going on
so from that point that's what they do
um they fly out to ithaca new york
they find sebastian cole they fly out
they find daniel at his home
and it turns out that all of the writers
are experiencing the exact
same thing uh they also have to go and
see the um the original parapsychologist
who wrote the book about
the kill creek house that got wayne
wright interested in in the whole thing
and so at this point they all figure out
what's going on and then they decide
that they have to go back to the kill
creek house
to find out how they can stop whatever
this force
is that is um pretty much ruining their
lives
so that's essentially how the story goes
i mean they end up having like all these
people you know
people die um terrible things happen i
forgot to mention too that right before
the end of the first part like before
they leave the kill creek house for the
first time like after the interview
that something really bad happens um not
to do with the paranormal or the
supernatural but something
really bad happens to one of the
characters
or to one of their family members i
guess and that kind of um
feeds into some stuff that happens later
on so they kind of all get back together
and uh you know wayne wright goes with
them and they decide they're going to go
back to kill creek
and the one of the first things they
want to do is knock down that brick wall
because they've had like dreams about it
and stuff and they want to see
like what's behind there maybe they can
figure out what
what this entity is that's causing this
haunting essentially that is apparently
powerful enough to follow them home
you know in the disparate cities where
they live so they want to figure out
what the secret of this house is
and that's essentially uh what they do
one great thing about this book um
it just seems like the description of it
it's amazing that this is kind of his
first horror novel like i said i knew
he'd
written other things um you know for tv
and whatnot but this being his first
horror novel it's actually
very cinematic it seems like it would be
like a really good
movie because just the um the
descriptions and stuff were so vivid
like i really could see it like running
like a movie like inside my head while i
was reading it
as i said the characters at the
beginning other than sam who's just like
a very likable
he's a little bit haunted by his past
he's you know having some hard luck and
stuff so you kind of like relate to him
right away he's a very everyman type
character
um so he's very likeable at the
beginning the other ones a little bit
well sebastian is a good character too
but the other two daniel who's like the
christian writer and tc moore who's like
the extreme
you know sex horror writer a little bit
over the top like a little bit
caricature-ish
but they actually like unravel more
layers to their character like unpeeled
as the story goes on which i thought was
really good
some people i saw a lot of people um
yeah i read some of the reviews of it on
goodreads most of them are
you know overwhelmingly positive because
this is a very entertaining
you know it's got some creepy imagery in
it and it seemed like a real page turner
like i didn't really have any
point where i was just kind of like oh
get on with it or that i was bored or
anything
i thought the pacing of it was very good
but one of the main complaints like a
lot of people
really didn't like uh the character of
tc more and also they didn't like
they said well it this has and and
i i get this this does have slightly a
little bit
of that problem that i think i talked
about when i was talking about that
richard layman book that i reviewed a
little while back
it has a little bit of that male writer
writing a female character
and kind of over sexualizing her and
it's not just the one female character
it's the other
you know the other female character kate
she's and pretty much
every time they are talked about
it's they talk about their body you know
what i mean which
i get that like a lot of male writers do
that when they're writing female
characters
it's like it didn't bother me that much
i guess because i'm kind of used to it
but some people that were on goodreads
that
you know they really really didn't like
it particularly the character of tc more
is like pretty much every single time
that she's
you know on the on screen or she's on
scene or whatever
it's like he's talking about what her
body looks like and it does get it is a
little strange because they don't really
do that for the male characters except
for daniel slaughter who
he's like the christian writer and he's
well he's a big
fat dude so there is so every time that
he's on see
on screen they talk about how fat he is
now i will say that
him being really overweight does
actually
kind of matter to the story later on but
like
not till the end but at the beginning
it's like some people were just kind of
like man every time this dude is on
there he's like hey you fat this
like you know the floorboard's creaking
underneath them and all this other kind
of stuff it's like he's fat we get it
but you know what i mean so there's a
little bit of that but like i said it
didn't really bother me um the story was
compelling the characters like i said
even though they seemed a little
stereotypical at the beginning
they actually got a lot more complex and
interesting
and um you know more like real people as
the story went along and as more
terrible [ __ ] happened
so so if so if you're kind of going
through the first half of the book and
you're just like man these characters
they don't seem like real people or just
like stick with it because it does
actually
they do actually seem more and more real
as the story goes on
and like i said particularly in the case
of the tc moore character
she um she's real prickly and real she's
kind of an [ __ ]
but there's a reason that she's like
that you know what i mean and
there's a reason that all of them are
like that so you can kind of forgive it
uh to
to an extent but yeah like i said this
this was a really entertaining book it
took me it's pretty long but it really
didn't take me
took me maybe a day and a half to finish
it um because it was just
i just kept getting you know compelled
to go back to it because
particularly when i got past the halfway
point and they
you know went and did the interview and
then they left the house and apparently
nothing
bad happened i was just kind of like huh
now that i was like kind of curious
as to like where it was going to go so
it went in a lot of directions i didn't
expect
also has a little bit well i don't even
know if a little bit a lot a twist
ending
and i didn't see it coming so i liked
that the end was sort of like a gut
punch like right at the very end i was
like oh [ __ ] you know what i mean
so i didn't see it coming maybe some
people will i don't know i didn't so so
i really liked that as well
i honestly think this would actually
probably
make a really really good movie if
anybody
if they ever want to make it into a
movie like i said i kind of saw it as a
movie in my head while i was
reading it because it just has a very
visual
very cinematic kind of style to it but
yeah and i would totally watch it
now as i said it's not a hugely it's a
haunted house story
um you know it's a story about the power
of storytelling
in a lot of ways um how stories about
things can become more important than
what is actually true or
you know if you tell a story enough
times or
you know tell a rumor enough times like
it eventually becomes true or that's
what gives it power
um because that's kind of how the house
gets its power
from its notoriety um it's sort of
so it's sort of like the house is almost
kind of like are the entities within are
like a living organism that feed off of
attention and they feed off of people's
pain and fear
uh so the house or the entities within
it are basically just trying to
draw people to it so that people will
tell
will tell stories about it and it will
just like make it stronger and stronger
so it's kind of like the shining in that
way where it's like
you know a building that is feeding off
of people's
fears essentially uh so that's kind of
where this story is coming from so like
i said it's not
you know the most original idea in the
world but [ __ ] man what is nothing it's
everything's been written but it's
i just really really enjoyed this a lot
um just a real
fun cinematic read had some real creepy
imagery in it
characters that started out kind of like
not i don't want to say cardboard cutout
but it started out a little bit
stereotypical but
got more complex and interesting like as
the story went on
uh but yeah it just had some twists and
turns that i didn't see coming
so you know i just had a really really
good time with this book
and kind of amazing that it's this first
horror novel
i don't know if he's written any sense
then but uh i guess i'll be on the
lookout for
his next one if he does another one but
yeah uh totally check it out like i said
came out in 2017
kill creek by scott thomas so check it
out if it sounds at all
interesting to you and i will see you on
the next one
bye